the following contains spoilers for the
upcoming season of Game of Thrones hey
guys today in this video I'm bringing is
confirmed that for the upcoming season
that's that are confirmed by leaked plot
and also support valley photos this list
will take a while so just sit back relax
and enjoy it let's start with the death
of the lord of horn he'll randyll Tarly
before we focus on those leaked photos
that'll confirm that randyll Tarly will
help Jamie to get high guard in fact
where found he is going to die let me
just say that Cersei will in the
upcoming season need to make a new
alliance since she killed the only
Lannisters strong ally with wildfire
well we don't have to wonder anymore
who's Circe's allies going to be since
it's been confirmed by leaked photos
that randyll Tarly is going to be one of
the new Lannister cell eyes in the
upcoming season who will probably be
awarded with placed in small Council but
a main result of this alliance will be
their March and Highgarden as I've
already reported the result of this
alliance is going to be Jaime Lannister
leading Lannister army along with
Randall and deacon Tarly leading their
Tarly army they're going to march in
Highgarden and also firmly photos based
in the outcome of the battle which will
result the genies and Randall's victory
which is by the way not surprising at
all Jaime and Randall will have numbers
they will outnumber Tyrell soldiers and
both of them have a lot of military
experience especially randyll Tarly who
is known as one of the best battle
commanders in Seven Kingdoms just before
I continue with the events that are
going to seal Randall's fate we have a
debt of one more major character the -
which is the result of alliance between
Lannisters and tourists into that of the
Queen of thorns that of Lady Olenna
Tyrell who pledged house Tyrell forces
to Daenerys Targaryen
while this march in the assault on hai
gardening's confirmed by leaked photos
according to leaked plot Jaime will also
confront Olenna Tyrell while being at
Highgarden
according to liquid lady Olenna will
admit to Jaime
everything about her she and
Littlefinger poison Joffrey which will
end with Jaime allowing Elena to drink
poison and to kill herself before
getting captured as I've already brought
you have a detail about this in my
previous videos I've also received a lot
of positive
reviews and comments like for an example
why would the Lana had made 2j mean that
she killed his firstborn son well the
answer is actually pretty simple if you
still remember conversation between lady
Elena and Petyr Baelish which happened
in 7th episode of season 5 a
conversation in which the queen of
torrents threatened Littlefinger and
said I promised you Lord Baelish that
our fates are joined together we
murdered the king if my house should
fall I will have nothing to hide at a
moment in me Jamie and Randle conquered
Highgarden
lady Elena will be aware that her life
is over that she can either kill herself
or become a hostage which would also
resulted her death eventually as we all
know that lady Elena is well known for
her intellect and sarcasm which
accompanies with her intelligence and
her cunning skills resulted with her
being popularly nicknamed the queen of
thorns this same lady Olenna Tyrell
where that her fate is sealed at a
moment in the Jamie is going to confront
her at Highgarden will admit everything
to Jamie because as she said herself she
has nothing to hide once her house falls
as we know her house had phone supported
by fact that lady Elena will be aware
that she is going to die one way or
another Lady Olenna will certainly admit
to Jamie everything since that's
something what would the lana do meaning
that the league plot seems to fit
perfectly with my novel and a Tyrell
which sadly makes league but once again
being pure truth as many times since
it's been leaked
after the conquering Highgarden and
after Jamie longing Lady Olenna to drink
poison Jamie and Randall with their
armies will march back home with the
carriages full of goods loaded from high
guard while Derek heading home
the nurses army will attack Jamie send
Randall's army and take an opportunity
to fire them on the open field then to
venture a lie which is confirmed by
leaked photos as well this huge battle
will start with the tracking ambush but
during the battle Daenerys will also be
a riding Robin how can I know for sure
well I obviously didn't see drawn in
leaked photos or from leaked photos you
can see a lot of smoke and bird
carriages which I believe is the result
of dragons fire braiding
battle will end with a lot of casualties
for both sides as you can see a lot of
that man on the ground but it certainly
is going to be the nurses victory during
this battle Randall and the guitar we
are going to be captured while bran will
save Jamie from almost getting killed
whereupon they are going to escape and
most likely go to Casterly Rock which
I've already explained you in details in
my video about fate of Jamie Lannister
embroider Lee photos from original
castle which will the big cats will Iraq
in which we can see Jaime and Bronn and
wolves
however while Jaime and Bronn will
manage to escape in the heat of the
battle Randall and they current won't be
that lucky this Denise's victory will be
very important for her without victory
then it will prove to her enemies that
everyone who won't bend the knee and
everyone who is going to betray her or
her allies will be punished
they explosively seen that happened on
filming set near or parted up the scene
that involve our technicians and a
burning stuntman could be an outcome of
Daenerys is anger entirely for joining
the Lannisters on their march in
Highgarden and for killing Lady Olenna
who became Danny's ally at the end of
previous season as you can see there was
a huge burst of flame and the stuntmen
was set on fire I can tell for sure
which character salmon was representing
but when he was set on fire someone
yelled Khaleesi
what sort of witchcraft is this now the
rising a question on these scenes such
as verdict great ball of fire came from
and which character is a stuntman
impersonating in my opinion the stuntman
was impersonating randyll Tarly who is
in my opinion going to be burnt alive by
Danny's dragon as a result of Randall's
betrayal over his sword house Tyrell and
for pledging his army to Lannisters the
man that held Kelly's see what sort of
witchcraft is this would be in this
theory Randall Santaquin Tarly
who will after days get a chance to bend
the knee and swear fealty to Daenerys
whereupon he is going to become the new
Lord of the horns Hill by now I broach
deaths of the Queen of thorns and the
death of randyll Tarly now let's focus
on that of the most cunning man in the
Seven Kingdoms the death of Petyr
Baelish in leaked plot there stated that
in the last episode of yup come
sensors going to sentence little fingers
to that which Aria will carry out I've
already brought your theory in which
little finger is going to die on his
first wedding night doctor he married
Sansa Stark the wedding that won't end
as little finger bones by this theory
wedding will happen upon little fingers
try to sense that he will pull the veil
truths back to the well unless Sansa
marries him while Jon Snow at this point
won't be at vina fall John will be a
dragon stone you might think the little
finger couldn't command to the connives
of the whale but be careful about that
and remember what happened in the fourth
episode of season six
don't forget the Knights of the Vale
were mobilised only because of Peter
only because of his manipulation
overlords Robin you might say that other
Lords from the Vale such as John Royce
the Lord of Runestone could decide to
stay to have Jon Snow
no matter a little fingers opinion but
you're wrong if some of the words from
the whale would obey Peters commands
they will be sentenced to death by the
Lord of the Vale by Lord Robin by the
Lord with whom can be manipulated and
who does as Peter says the Lord that
mobilized the Knights of the Vale all
because Littlefinger wanted the Lord
that almost through the head of house
Rhodes out of the moon door and only
because Peter wanted in the first place
while little finger also spared his life
which means that the fate of words from
the Vale is a little fingers hands all
the lords from the Vale are vessels of
house Iran and have to do as Lord of the
Vale or Robin commands or otherwise they
will be executed by this theory sensible
except Peters marriage proposal and you
have to know that at this point send
someone be alone and Vina fell there
will also be Arya Stark who will already
need which to Brotherhood without
banners and hound whereupon the Hound is
going to tell us the truth about
Littlefinger the truth about beers
betrayal Ned Stark as this theory
continues sensible actually Mary Petyr
Baelish leading to their wedding night
now you might wonder why Littlefinger
even want to marry Sansa why would he
insist that much well we all know his
plans we all know about his goal that he
has in his head
the goal and thought that he shared with
Samson season 6 finale the picture in
which he sees him on the Iron Throne and
Sansa by his side also Littlefinger
wants to marry Sansa because he is still
going to try to make her as a rule when
ofall and the queen in the north you
might be confused at this point and I
understand that just wait a little bit
more
Peter Baelish from the very beginning
wanted to marry Catelyn Stark but upon
realizing that it's not going to happen
not even after he killed her husband
Littlefinger has focused his intentions
on trying to make sense as the arrow min
fell which along with his idea to marry
her will give him the Norden army the
big amount of soldiers that he needs in
favour to achieve his goal in favor to
win the Iron Throne peter baelish
demanded orchestrated the assassination
of John Aaron which led that start to
become the new hand of the king
which have been part of his plan as well
Littlefinger's we can call the genius
plan back in season one was to kill John
and rain with the help of John Soane
wife which he did and then to make Ned
Stark as the new handled King whereupon
she helped Ned to figure out who job for
his real father is since he knew that it
would lead honourable man to reveal the
truth to everyone else which lets Ned
stars beheading all of this foods little
fingers game he threw the Seven Kingdoms
into a state of chaos from which he
personally benefited now that we know
Peters ultimate plan which he revealed
to Sansa in the gods suit of inner fault
which is to sit on the Iron Throne which
census star by his side and through all
the Westeros as we could see by his face
expression Johnston being proclaimed as
the king in the north
if his main obstacle on his way to
accomplish his plan as Littlefinger says
himself his plan which was led Sheen to
conquer the Iron Throne contains Sansa
Stark as his wife and there's a queen in
the north which would provide him the
support of the north the necessary
amount of the army to have a chance of
conquering the Iron Throne which
Littlefinger almost accomplished by
helping Sansa to retake the Winterfell
from Bolton's but Lady Mormon disrupted
baelish's plan to set sense as the Queen
in the north determined innocent speech
which had other Lords to proclaim John
as
in the north peter baelish the man who
betrayed Ned Stark in favor to set up a
fight between volts and lions
the man had poison Joffrey Lannister on
job for his own wedding with an
assistance of Olenna Tyrell to save
Sansa Stark and then that same safe girl
already torched by Lannisters was handed
over to even more sick oppressor Ramsay
Bolton all in favour to turn the north
against Bolton and to give him an
opportunity to set Sansa the Queen in
the north demanded first married and
then killed Liza rain and how he's
manipulating with her son Robin all in
favour to have his own army not
particularly his because the Knights of
the Vale are under command of Lord Robin
but Robin is as I've already said
manipulated and is now we can say under
the command of Littlefinger as I've
already said in my previous videos
Littlefinger played a big role in John's
victory actually if Petyr Baelish didn't
decide to help John Ramsay Bolton would
have been still alive and would have
been in charge of inner foul while John
would have been dead but don't think
that Petyr Baelish came to save John
don't think that he would even come to
save Sansa if it wasn't for his own good
all of this well finger played in favor
to bring back in a photo Sansa Stark
which she managed to accomplish but his
main plan to set Sansa as the role
Winterfell and as the Queen in the north
he did not accomplish the man that made
all of these actions regardless from the
pain that he brought to many people this
man Petyr Baelish will doubtlessly gives
his best to make his plans come true
which could bring more innocent people
in danger of his intrigues
Littlefinger's plan will be either to
make a conflict between Jon Snow and the
north or to arrange on that while he
will marry Sansa to make sure that this
time after she killed the last man
connected to House Stark
after his head senses a rule being felt
to make sure that senses his wife device
which he will by his plan manipulate
with
just as he is manipulating with Lord
Robin which would bring him the northern
army leading him one step further on
conquering the island round but
Littlefinger won't be aware that senses
manipulating him that sense I found out
from Arya that his response
for her father's beheading that's the
moment in which dividing between Santa
Fe is going to happen the moment which
will lead to their wedding night which
is conceived by two stark sisters by
Sansa and Arya vile little finger and
sense are being alone in their room
Oh Petyr baelish's convinced that his
picture of them together has finally
came true that very moment by distillery
sense I will put a dagger down
Littlefinger strode the moment in which
sensible entered the room the moment in
which we had two senses the moment in
which Arya is taking off Santa's face
while holding a dagger on Pierce Road
where upon re-skilling him while Sam
sighs watching I'm aware that most of
you right now are questioning the
accuracy of this theory I'm aware that
most of you think that Arya can't fire
someone space if that person is still
alive but as I've already said you're
wrong back in the final episode of
season 5 there was a scene with jerking
her garb or Arya space the seemingly
jerking poisoned himself the scene in
which Arya became blind for a while that
scene confirms that the faceless lannis
essence can bear the face of a person
that is not dead a person that is still
alive which makes this theory in which
our is using senses face and his killing
loom finger while Sansa is entering the
room much more possible and I have to
admit this jury would fit perfectly to
the Game of Thrones series in my opinion
this theory would come true considering
the previous events and that's mostly
considering the writing of co-creators
David Benioff and Dan Weiss this theory
also might not come true there are a lot
of possibilities from how Littlefinger
might be killed but one is certain Petyr
Baelish won't survive the upcoming
season these are only three deaths that
will happen in the upcoming season but
there are also many more which I'm going
to bring you guys in the following days
in conclusion I suggest you to brace
yourself because this is only a part one
there are at least two more videos about
the deaths in the upcoming season to
come hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did please make sure to subscribe to
our Channel and I hope to see in the
next time peace
[Music]
you